hi my name is cindy cheswick
and i'm an associate professor of
biomedical engineering at the university
of michigan
and i'm going to be your moderator for
this session which is entitled
developing and distributing novel
electrode technologies
so you're going to hear from a range of
groups that have each developed
a novel tool enabled by the brain
initiative for
electrophysiology and each of them are
going to talk about you know the unique
capabilities of their
tool and then also some of the
challenges
um of distributing those to a broad
group of neuroscientists or planning
some of that distribution
um so throughout the talks we're gonna
be monitoring uh for questions
and uh at the end we will have a live uh
question and answer session so we're
we're looking forward to having a
conversation at the end of this
so without further ado um we will go
ahead and get started with the
presentations
so today i'm going to talk to you about
carbon fiber arrays
for high density neural interfaces and
so we've been very fortunate to be
funded by the brain initiative
to both develop and distribute
these tools to to neuroscience labs
so the core mission of my lab
is uh motor neuroprosthetic so what that
means is that we're trying to take
signals from the nerve and the brain
and use them to control multi-degree of
freedom finger movements
and while there's really a lot of things
that you can accomplish with a utah
array
ultimately we're not going to have
enough and so that made me very
interested
very early on in carbon fiber arrays
that was based on the work of tk kozai
and tim gardner
in showing that you can use a eight
micron carbon fiber so an electrode
smaller than a neuron
in order to record in the brain um so in
my lab
we turned this into an array of
individual carbon fibers so what you're
seeing there is sort of our older work
from 2015
um these eight micron carbon fibers are
about 150 microns apart
and you know due to the sort of strength
of carbon um
if you can have 500 to 750 microns of
free length
and you can still just drive that into
the brain despite their eight micron
size
so you're seeing that in a rat brain on
the right and what you're seeing is it's
partially carbon fiber and there's also
a little bit of help
coming from mechanical silicon supports
so over the last few years we've
developed and used a wide variety of
these devices
um so on the left is our older workhorse
where we were first getting these into
the brain
by a dissolving peg as they inserted um
you can also get pretty much anywhere in
the brain with a cannula
you know and then have a carbon carbon
fiber for the last 500 microns or so
um but obviously you know the peg is a
pain the cannula is definitely
undesirable
um so we've been developing and i think
our finally and what we can call beta
testing
for devices that can sort of go anywhere
in a rat brain
so what you're seeing here is a device
where there's you know at the very end
it's all carbon fiber
um and then there's you know you can see
these gradations going back
and that is gradually widening silicon
to support the length of that carbon
fiber and there's a channel inside of
the silicon
that holds the carbon fiber and we have
three millimeter six millimeter and nine
millimeter versions of this
we did a lot of alpha testing trying to
get uh get them to insert
with as little material as possible this
is sort of you know the final dimensions
we ended up with
and we can attach this to any kind of
connector and you're looking at 16
channel
arrays here so there's a lot of really
cool electrodes and you're going to hear
about a lot of them in this symposium so
why why might you as a neuroscientist
want to use carbon fibers
um and i think that it comes down to you
know if you're if you need
the mechanical properties of the carbon
fiber or if you need the chemical
properties
of the carbon fiber so in addition to
being uh you know much
better able to penetrate tissue um it's
also surprisingly robust
to work with um so this is you know
an early version of our nerve device and
it is embedded in silicone which helps
um but you can see we can run this over
these are these are carbon fibers with a
glass capillary ten thousand times
um and you know this this same test does
not work for silicon
for example so what this means in
practice is it can handle more surgical
uh handling um also uh carbon fibers are
very commonly used
in neuroscience for uh sensing dopamine
and this is a large part of the
development effort
that we've been doing and right now
we're in the process of uh
debugging new rigs and the the becker
burke and darris
labs on for 16 channel uh fast can
cyclic voltammetry
using these new devices
also i'll say you know it's not just
about the quantity of channels it's also
about the quality
and so i'll show you histology in a
second but these electrodes are
particularly non-damaging um
and my student alyssa welley spent a lot
of time sort of engineering the tip to
the point where we can get a very low
impedance electrode with a very
still a very small cross section for
recording
and that has sort of enabled us to get
to the point where we see
you know good units on basically every
channel and this this was just published
in the journal of neural engineering
um you know i'm showing you the cued on
the top chronic on the bottom
and this work has sort of led me to
think okay if you're if you're not
seeing a unit at at least 100 microns or
100 microvolts or more
there's probably something wrong with
the brain or your electrode
another thing that this is particularly
good for is again when you when you have
something
very small you want to record from that
is nonetheless sort of hard to penetrate
so
um our collaborators uh tim bronze and
ahmad jamon just
uploaded this paper to bio archive um
using carbon fibers to record
from rat vagus nerve and so that's a 200
to 300 micron structure you have to
penetrate epineurium
and we've been really pleased with the
signal to noise ratios that we can get
on these
uh carbon fiber electrodes and even on
the lower left there you can see
what appears to be tracking an action
potential across four different
electrodes on our 16 channel array
another good capability of these carbon
fibers
is that we believe we can pretty closely
identify the location of the tip
or at least we can identify the look the
uh the tip of the hole
that the electrode was in um so this is
you know based on 2d images my student
circled 3d images i made a 3d movie all
the way down
and the greener neurons and again we
know that these electrodes
land very close to the neurons
so i'm showing data on the right from
a 13-week implant
and you know we and others have
published histology on carbon fibers but
it's still always
it's really cool every time to see a
similar neuron density
um on the top and on the bottom so these
are not statistically significantly
different
in you know the number of neurons in
these images
and you're seeing half the array here um
where uh you know we are able to sort of
you know advance the image until the
the black hole disappears and see where
the tip of the electrode is
um and you know we these are uh action
potentials that we recorded
from day 84 on these electrodes
so you know we we have every every
channel has a closest neuron and a
biggest waveform
um we're not diluted enough to think
it's going to be that simple
so it's going to take a lot of work to
sort of show you know whether or not we
can actually associate individual
neurons with their waveforms
um but the higher density of neurons is
really consistent with you know seeing
more single units
um that you can sort on these electrodes
um so you know in conclusion if you need
a robustly inserting electrode or you
want to localize it precisely or you
want to record
dopamine i think this is a really good
technology
so um in terms of distribution we've had
the good fortune to be able to
distribute a lot of devices through the
uh neuronex program so uh yusik yoon
runs the mint hub at university of
michigan
where anybody can google us go to our
website
if you click carbon micro threads you
know it brings up a forum that goes
right to um my excellent full-time
technician um juliana ritchie
who then you know contacts labs and we
figure out you know what they need for
their experiments
and through this program we've been able
to distribute
345 devices to 33 labs
and so among those 33 labs i think only
one of them
wanted the actual picture that was in
our data sheet
and we were really surprised everybody
else has wanted some degree of
customization for their application
and it is a benefit of you know having a
few
you know adjustable by hand steps that
we're able to accommodate a lot of these
requests
um i do think for distribution this
would be really challenging for a
company
and so you know to talk about the cost
of manufacturing this you know from a
non-company academic lab
we actually did a detailed cost study
within our own group of what it cost
us to make these i'm sort of
anticipating you know what we're going
to do
after the end of some of these programs
um
and i can let me start by playing you
know there is a remaining by hand
step which is the laying of carbon
fibers um this is a video from my
collaborators lab
actually showing it being done not by
hand so there's there's a robot an
extruder
micro on stage and you actually see a
carbon fiber being uh
laid down on the pad play that one more
time and it actually gets sort of
sucked into the silicon channel during
fabrication
um so the materials and clean room cost
to us
is 160 dollars a device um if you add
in you know all of the time of people
doing the fabrication that comes up
350. um we kind of liked that number
um and then we they made us include
management overhead administration
um and then it becomes six hundred
dollars a device to sort of what it
costs um
as a whole at the university of michigan
um so in practice
we're sort of you know uh writing small
bits of grant for you know a few
thousand dollars worth of devices
um and so but we're trying to figure out
a way to make that
uh sustainable to you know our existing
collaborators
um so i think this is you know we're
primarily distributing you know in
addition to neuronex
via you know collaborations where we as
the engineers go into a small service
role
so this we're very proud to help jill
becker get preliminary data towards an
r01
on social support and addiction
which is going to use the dopamine
sensing capabilities of the arrays
we're also really excited to participate
in uh galoot caleb's new project
where we're uh we're going to use the
penetration capabilities of the arrays
to penetrate some octopus uh epineurium
apparently the tentacles have
a lot of neurons in them so we're very
excited about this project as well
um and we're sort of continuing to sort
of do you know small
in-service uh collaborations to try to
get these out to
um you know the biggest electrode users
um that have been
identified through you know our
neuro-necks and through our
internal projects so with that i just
want to thank my lab
the people that do the most work on the
carbon fibers are patel alyssa welley
joseph leitner
and giuliana richie and i'd be happy
please enter your questions in the box
and i'd be happy to
answer them by email as well next
up we have uh chung-ji from rice
university
thanks cindy for the introduction i'm
chongxie from
rice university the department of
electrical and computer engineering
so today uh i'm going to talk to you
about
our effort on the autoflexible very
electrons
so this is an effort we have been
working on for the past the past
six years thanks to the organizer for
this
opportunity to present our work here
all right so uh here is a very
uh very simple short r line
so since we are uh in the relatively
earlier stage than most of other
speakers in this session
so i'll advertise more on the capability
the current capability than our effort
of this and also flexible electrons we
have been working out
and later on our touch upon the effort
we just initiated to disseminate these
elixirs to other labs
so uh we are among the believers that uh
electors need to be flexible to uh to
become friendly to the surrounding tsu
so we took a step further and make them
also correctable
and i'll show you how we make them
stably record from
individual neurons for many months and
i'll also show you
how we scale things up to uh to the
scale of thousands of neurons
all right here are a few examples of our
electrodes as you can see in this
figures that
our electrodes are very similar in terms
of the design
from any other passive ethic
recording intellectuals the only
difference we make here is that we make
them from
polymers and we make them between each
scene
the overall thickness as you can see if
you measure across such a probe
it's just a micron and the rationale
we're running here is that the
flexibility of such a device
is determined by the bending stiffness
of the structure
and the bending stiffness if you look at
the equation is proportional
to the young's modulus and also key to
the cube
to the third of thickness
so that means if we switch the material
of
the probe from rigid materials such as
silicon and
metal to polymers we gain a lot in terms
of flexibility
but a more effective modulator here is a
significant device
if we make a device from 10 micron in
sickness
which was the typical second expect when
we started this project
if we make it down to one micron we gain
10 times in sickness but we
we gain a thousand times in flexibility
so given this principle we were able to
engineer the flexibility engineer the
device to maximize the
flexibility of these devices
so we call them an electronic stress or
neutral
net so with this we are able to make
extremely flexible devices here example
of such a
device this is 128 channel device
uh suspended in water these devices do
not
self-stand in air they were just the
collapse
but if you're suspending water and drop
a couple of
water nearby and you can see that they
are driven
quickly due to the extreme flexibility
if you were to measure them
quantitatively here we have example
measuring the bending force
of a suspended device with the
atomic force microscopy so that you can
see
the bending force is actually the single
new
single digit in nano newton range just
for your information this single digit
magnetism is
within the similar range of a single
cell strike and force
so again this is a few choices super
scene structure of us
of such a device all right with such a
flexible device
the difference we can make is once we
use fan such a device here you can see
the triple the
image required while the implant is
still in the life
of the living animal you can see an
implanted electrode i've shown
i see we have rhythm here it's getting
along with the surrounding capillary
very well with
no no pvp leakage at all
on the right you can see that there is
no observed
neuronal thick degeneration happening
over a course
of amounts during implantation
all these data are published a couple of
years i refer you
to this paper for more details
so far i've shown you the evidence that
these devices get along with such long
normal features very well you may wonder
that
whether they report at all because we
make the electoral so
seem that it's highly questionable
whether they can maintain
their electoral functionality at all so
back then there were a lot of questions
but it turns out they can record just as
nicely as any other passive
according intellectuals here is a few
examples showing how
you record and the typical unit isolated
with
from this recording
and the real difference we can make here
is that
we can actually turn this recording to
be very very stable
so this table here has too meanings one
is short-term stability and the other is
long-term stability
so let me unfold here a little bit more
so
in the long term because the electrodes
breath along with the certain tissue
very well
we can maintain a relatively stable
performance for this electrode
over a time course of months or up to a
year
if you look at the measurements of the
recording performance of those light
shows the impedance
and the unit yield and the recorded
anti-accident potential amputees are
relatively stable
over the course of up to a year so far
we have tested
many many of those devices and in most
cases
we can yield a stability over six months
or up to a year
and the failure often comes from
connectors
just as we expected and we have tested
this electrical cmys
that we just started with testing the
non-human primates as well
we have tested uh brain structures such
as cortex
and excited to use them for information
such as the campus
so this is about the long-term stability
and in the short term many of us know
that
if due to the mechanical mismatch
between the implanted electrodes
and the surrounding softer tissue
even in short term there are relative
motion
happening between the electrodes with
respect to the tissue
so you don't get to record from the
video long
very stable you often use them
after a few hours here is a
is an example of our electrodes uh
unless you see
like 128 arrays
and on the on the right you see the
isolated unit of
other array each dot here represents
a estimated estimated location of
one of those units during one recording
session
now if we come back a day or two
after you would expect
another set of recording but whether you
can match those individual dots
and conclude we are recording from the
same url
so it's hard to say i mean let me show
you
what it actually looks like when we
actually do that
now let's zoom into one of those dots
that means we look at the recording of
this one single unit
if we unfold this piece of data and
present the waveforms
recorded by the neighboring channels
surrounding this
neuron you see there are four by eight
waveforms
showing this uh showing the recording
from the same aura
that's from the neighboring channels
surrounding this mirror
now that's the first piece of data all
right if we were to play this video
here each frame here show is showing you
a piece of data from one hour of
recording
and this recording work was continuous
for over two months and now i'll just
fast through this video
because it takes a very long time to
show you the whole picture
if we if i go all the way from beginning
and to the end you can see that there is
really
little change in in the waveforms
that's because it doesn't it didn't
change at all
very much at all so i hope
this piece of data can convince you that
this first of all this relaxes didn't
drift or move much over the time course
of
almost two months and the recording was
pretty stable and it was stable enough
for us
to patch up all the data and
continuously track the same url
over two months now let's
look at how we can actually scale this
type of recording
up to a few thousand
so here is a example of a
piece of 128 channel of that device
and over the years past years we have
put in significant effort to diversify
the designs of
the context arrangement and geometry of
those contacts
and we have concluded or concluded
a standard design of those mod those
devices
and we turn them all into 128 channel
modules
and we practice a lot of surgery and and
got
a standard practice to implant many many
of those modules in one
animal as you can see on the right here
is the example of eight of those devices
implanted in one area with a spacing
in the inner cortex with a spacing of
just 150 microns
so with this capability we can achieve
very high density recordings using these
delightful
an example of eight of those 128
channel devices as you can see covering
a area in the v1
region of an override and this
this dot already showing is showing you
the anticipated
implantation location of each contact of
those
1024 in total channels
and this is the microct data showing you
where they
really end up being as you can see they
all squish me to this tiny volume
about just one microliter
and here is a example of our recorded
data
just like a typical passive
electro array we can record local field
potential in this
region and we can isolate all neurons
firing all the spikes that's being shown
in this movie
and to conclude we have all the data
summarized and
this talk is showing you all the units
we sorted out there were over a thousand
units recorded by this 1024
channel array within this a
uh about a millimeter cube of brain
tissue
with this data we are able to play a lot
more interesting games for example we
can
look at the connectivity we think we're
gonna just say
besides the example
so with this sampling
we can cover a significant region of one
word region for example in this case
we had eight outposts sorry ten dollars
128
arrays covering a significant portion of
b1 and higher order visual regions in
the mouse
and this video is showing the
the electrical coverage and the local
field potential
and all the unit activities and
given the same electrodes we can try to
distribute them across the products as
well
in this case we have 20 of those devices
covering a variety
of various cortical regions again the
electrodes
and local field potential and unit
activities
in this experiment so
with that i hope that i have shown you
that uh this aquaflex voice
electrons can help us safely record
where we prolong time duration
and we can possibly scale them up to
record
thousands of neurons at a time now let's
talk about
how difficult it is or what difference
it is
here to really send busy light shows to
other labs
compared to conventional approaches and
i'll also discuss about the challenges
here
so there are many two uh difficulties
in terms of sending the i just saw the
labs first
we divided we needed to develop a
specialized
assembly and implementation strategy in
order to
implement those ultraflexible devices as
we as you saw
these devices are extremely flexible
they won't
go into the brain by themselves we need
to design a
a shuttle device in this case we simply
use the array of tungsten wires and
pre-assemble those
flexible shanks onto those wires glued
together by
attack polyethylene glycol and when we
lower the assembly into the brain and we
retract the structure the cut aware
arrays
and leave the probes inside so in terms
of
dissemination we will need to
pre-assemble
everything which is menu many work
assemble everything before we shift them
to our collaborating labs
our collaborators we simply need to
implant them
using a standard stereotactic technique
so the other difficulty was is
specialized the backhand
in this effort we collaborate with
company caused by gadgets and we also
took a
existing working strategy development
on frank's food and using
this set of head stages this uh this set
of stackable head stages
we can scale things up to a few thousand
up to three thousand channels in a
behaving animal
so with that i would like to discuss
future challenges
no one of those challenges we are trying
to address
is to standardize the fabrication and
also
standardize the assembly procedure which
is currently
manual and pretty laborious and we're
currently in the sdr projects
working with bike edges to improve
around this
brand and the other difficulty was
to uh to really surgically implant so
many
devices and also securely stick
the headstays onto the head of the
animal
and that surgery like this typically
take eight to nine
hours in our lives and if we were
oh if we were if we could
turn this bulky headstage into some
basic chips find it on those devices
it will simplify things a lot
very much so we're uh we're
collaborating with
a few groups to work along this britain
on this friend as well
so with that i'd like to uh thank you
for your attention
and appreciate all my lab members
working on this project
especially my student and the current
postdoc
jump to adele he did most of the work i
presented here
and also my collaborators learn one
advice as well and lauren friends
visit ucsf and materials cousin uh
gadgets
and thank you for all the fun and
support from
nice and well thank you for your
attention
and our next speaker is jim harris from
the media farm
thank you today i would like to tell you
two
short stories about two generations of
electrophysiology probes that were
developed
by my group at hhmi genealogy research
campus
the first locally and the second
through an international consortium of
donors
so the first one is about conventional
silicon probes and i think it's
a useful lesson for people who live in
academic environments because we
operated most of this within an academic
environment like
technology based it was entirely driven
by users
i am not a electrophysiologist and i do
not use silicon probes for my own work
so shortly after i got to janelia in
2009 i had people in my office
saying there are these things called
silicon probes but they don't have
enough sights on a shank they don't have
enough sights on a probe
and we need to put more than one probe
on an animal in order to push forward
this is 2009 so at the time a 16 channel
probe was an exotic
piece of hardware uh and so i responded
to that by looking at the available
technology then sold by neuronexus
developed at the university of michigan
um
and and thought well i think that
available fabrication technology
could do a bit better the technology
from neural nexus at that time was
late 90s um capability and there had
been some commercial advancements that
would make it better
so i thought all right you know we can
do up to 64 channel probes and maybe 16
site shanks it would be better if we
could do more
and the problem with more channels on a
probe is that if you were going to use
these in freely moving mice
the cables were unwieldy there were no
multiplexed head stages in 2009
but little tiny company called intent
technologies was selling a 16 channel
multiplexer chip that we thought
could be used the trouble was it didn't
work
with silicon probes and so we bought 160
of them so they could change
a design feature of it so that
the low frequency cutoff was shifted and
that's how we built the first available
multiplexer head stages
the probe development however is
somewhat less happy
we first tried with a commercial fab in
california called imt
and we tried to replicate the neural
nexus process and unfortunately one of
the critical
materials that they needed did not was
not available and they
absolutely and completely failed to
develop it
we spent more than a quarter of a
million dollars and walked away
absolutely empty-handed however later
ceteris massimonitis used that same
foundry and they succeeded in getting
good probes
by using only processes that were
in-house and perfected
the the second trial was at the uc
berkeley fab where that material was
available
the difficulty was is that we spent 70
percent of our money calibrating tools
and only 30
of our money actually making things we
got probes
but it was really painful and so
the lesson was in that case that you can
do it
but it's really hard to manufacture
something if you want to manufacture it
reproducibly in a teaching fab
uh it can be done but you really have to
spend a lot of money
uh teaching fabs are there to teach i
don't resent that fact i just want to
you know make people aware that
manufacturing that environment is really
a struggle
and so what we finally ended up doing is
is moving to the nist fab which has a
program that external contractors
especially if they're
working for non-profits like hhmi can
use their capability we
changed the design radically to
something we thought was simpler
we got a lot of probes the lessons we
got from that is
it life is better if you have a great
process engineer and
we had a young lady named andrea price
who was just spectacularly good at
trying something failing trying
something failing and trying a third
thing
and succeeding and having nothing but
good news for her weekly reports
i think we could have learned more from
experts we tried pretty hard
but we didn't learn enough and if i had
to do this cycle over again i would try
harder
and i think we were a little cautious we
should have tried hard stuff
sooner go ahead and make what you want
to really make and if it doesn't work
back off instead of the other way around
but you need someone committed to
selling probes if you're going to finish
this and that's one of the issues
the world doesn't need another probe
paper it needed probes
so the issue was lithography is is that
the
the development of the original probes
was done with quite modest lithography
we stuck with that modest lithography
quite a long time and finally decided to
use something called projection
lithography which was in 2008 available
almost no university clean room it is
now available in most of them
it was it came online and missed about
the time that we thought let's go ahead
and do this right and so we
ended i ended this project with making a
probe with a 64-channel shank
it was only 78 microns wide which fit my
criteria
you could have gotten 64 channel shank
probes before
but they were so wide they were not
stable in a chronic implant in a rodent
and then another probe with two
32-channel sites this is by far the most
popular probe that came out of this you
can buy these things
now from this little company called
cable generotech
and so my lesson in this is
dissemination is
is has to be committed at the very
beginning if you're not committed to
demonstrating the disseminating on day
one you just shouldn't do this unless
you absolutely feel your own science
need a new probe
you need someone fully committed to
selling something that was not me
and luckily tall holtzman came along and
he spent two years of 12-hour days
creating a market and these are now
successful probes that are used around
the world
um the second story i want to tell you
about is about neuropixels these are
cbos programmable probes and there were
two problems that we left with
one is i didn't want to wire out more
than 64 channels
and i couldn't make more than 64
channels on a probe that i could make
and so you needed to go to a
professional
fabrication facility so we needed better
lithography
you can get 384 channels on a shank if
you can do better lithography than you
can do at nist
the second thing is is that you needed
to integrate amplifiers and multiplexers
because you don't want to wire out a 384
channel cable off a mouse
and so you need fully capable cmos from
design
fabrication assembly and testing testing
costs
as much money as fabrication does you
need a manufacturing commitment on day
one that was when i went looking for
somebody to do this
my first condition was if you don't make
them and sell them i'm not going to give
you any money
and you need someone that's committed to
selling them that's not so easy
you know i don't know how to collect
sales tax in brazil
um and the third thing is you need a
support plan who's who's gonna who's
gonna answer the phone if somebody calls
and what does that do to the price
and the and the breadth of impact and so
my my recipe for this is look write a
spec
even if you're going to make something
yourself you should write a spec what
must it do
and then ask yourself does anyone but me
care it's great it's great fun to make a
thing in a fab
it's almost never worth it but if no one
else needs it and you don't need it to
do your own science
and then the question is it worth it
from a dollar standpoint
real cmos design and delivery costs
several million dollars to
engineer and a couple of three years and
then you need to produce something like
about a million dollars worth of
material to maintain a device in a
modern fab
if you're not going to go through that
you're going to become obsolete quickly
and i want to emphasize again that the
fabrication of the chip is
never most of the cost it's tied up in
all the other steps of making something
and so just very briefly neuropixels got
over all of those humps not
all without trials and failures in 2019
they delivered 3 230 probes to more than
230 labs there are now that those
numbers are over 4 000.
they're sold at cost 1200 euros each
support is free meaning it is provided
to people who do it out of the goodness
of their hearts mostly by my group at
genealia
but other founder labs have been
generous in their time of answering
questions and helping people
the two lower pictures the lady on the
left is heidi hinting the lady on the
right is chris heiberger
they are the lawyers at hhmi that made
these contracts without them this would
never have happened
so what's going on now is that we are
testing a new probe which is a third the
size and so you can put two on a mouse
768 channels
selectable among 10 000 sites weighs
less than a gram
you'll be able to buy these in about a
year and a half
and the nih has uh has generously agreed
to fund what i think is the end of the
line
the what i call terminal technology a
probe that you can see on the left there
that we call nxt
has a tiny base it has no head stage
we think that that it will allow you to
record brain wide limited only by the
number of shanks you're willing to
insert in the brain
you generate an immense amount of data
that's challenging to transmit out
but it's a solvable problem the world
knows how to do high speed data
transmission
and so in conclusion completion requires
a commitment to manufacturing
and distribution that costs time
it costs money there's opportunity cost
if you're a graduate student or a
postdoc this is not what you're supposed
to be doing
you need a plan as to who's going to do
that who's not trying to either get a
phd or finish their postdoc
thank you and now i'm going to turn the
ball over to
allison urita
hi everyone thank you for being here
today my name is allison aveda and i
work at lawrence livermore national
laboratory as a staff engineer within
the center for bioengineering
and the center for microorganic
technology and today i'll be giving a
really brief overview of the work that
we've done underneath the brain
initiative
focused on the distribution of flexible
polymer microelectrode arrays
for multi-species applications
so to start off with i wanted to go into
what we're actually distributing so at
livermore we focus on creating flexible
polymer microelectrode arrays for
electrophysiological recordings
an example of this is seen on the upper
left hand side in that picture
so that white block you see on the right
is a connector that leads out to the
electronics and on the other end
you see those tiny little forks those
are the areas that actually go into the
brain and at the very tip of those are
the microelectrode arrays
so far we've created channel counts
ranging from 32 to 128 channels
i say so far because we're actually
working on higher channel count devices
as well
but i'll go into that later on at
livermore we can process these using a
robust process technology
and so we use standard mems fabrication
techniques to make all of our devices
and what's great about our facilities is
that we actually have tools
specifically set aside to fabricate
these devices and so we can do all of
our fabrication
under iso 13 485 quality control
procedures
in addition this is a platform
technology so it can be expandable
and we've created devices ranging from
animal to human use although today i'll
be focusing specifically on animal use
devices
and so the benefits to our polymer
probes are that they are thin and
flexible and related to this
our collaborators have seen long
lifetimes so our main collaborator and
the head pi of this project is lauren
frank at ucsf
and his group has seen lifetimes of up
to 250 days when implanted in rats
in addition they've demonstrated
large-scale recordings
as well as single-unit stability and so
to that i want to show this plot here
which was published in 2019
out of lauren's group and so on the
left-hand side of that y-axis you see
the number of units measured per
electrode
on the right hand side you see the
number of units measured per shank and
this
is a 16 channel shank and so with this
graph you can see that
his group was able to track and monitor
single units using our devices over at
least 160 days
and so using this technology we were
really excited and
encouraged by these pro this result and
so we wanted to go ahead and try and
distribute these and get these into more
people's hands
and so i wanted to walk through the
steps and that we take to actually get
these devices out the door
and so the first step involves the
microfabrication of these devices again
this is done in the clean room at
livermore
and so the first step involves taking a
substrate wafer so silicon wafer
and depositing a layer of polyemit on
top so that's that yellow layer
the next step is to deposit a thin film
metal so this will define all of the
trace metal as well as the electrode
metal
we can then pattern the metal using
standard lithographic techniques
we can then deposit another layer of
polymer this will act as the insulation
layer
and finally we can pattern that polymer
and expose the electrode as well as
define the outline of the device itself
and then we can peel the device off of
the substrate wafer and we now have a
fully flexible micro electric array
and so the next step after these come
out of the clean room is to assemble
them
and so the first step is to connectorize
the device so you can see in that blue
circle that's where we add a
in this example a 36 pin omnetix
connector although we can do other types
of connectorization as well
the next step after that is to then
electroplate so
these devices when they come out of the
clean room have platinum
microelectrode surfaces and so we can
actually modify that surface using
electroplating to make it more
sensitive to picking up
electrophysiological signals
and so in these two examples here we can
show that we can plate pita on the
left-hand side and platinum iridium on
the right-hand side
and so the p-dot layer is actually that
really dark
layer that you see over the top row of
electrodes and the bottom is the bare
platinum
and then on the right-hand side the
platinum iridium are the darker gray
films that you see and then you can see
three platinum bare platinum electrodes
interspersed throughout as
contrast
and so finally the next step is to
prepare these devices for surgery
and so again because these devices are
fully polymer
they can't actually go into the brain on
their own and so we have to devise and
fabricate these
silicon stiffeners to help them get into
the brain
and so that's what you see in box a and
so that's a silicon stiffener um you can
see that there is a channel etched down
the middle of the shank
and so the first step is that we apply
what's called here glue so that's
basically polyethylene glycol
or peg and so we apply a little bit at
the very top
when we melt the peg that'll wick down
the middle of the shank
down the entire length we can then flip
that over which is seen in box c
and attach it to the probe so the peg
will adhere the probe to the stiffener
and in box d you see a fully attached
device
and so what this actually looks like
under a microscope is seen here at the
very bottom
so this is a two shank device you can
see that it's been plated with pdot
and so the probe is on top and then
underneath that you can actually see the
silicon stiffener peeking out
and so finally this is an example of a
fully assembled device that's ready to
ship
and so this particular device was a
practice device it's made fully of
polyamide only
it's not used for actual recording it's
what we send out to collaborators so
that they can practice and refine their
surgical technique
and so you can see at the very top
that's a 3d printed dummy
dummy omnitics and then at the very
bottom is a silicon stiffener
and then through the middle that t is
actually a polyamide wing which aids in
the surgery
and so once these actually get into
people's hands um
this is i'm going to walk through how
they do the surgery so
you can see here they attach the probe
to a surgical arm which is this gray arm
sticking down
i've also labeled the connector the wing
the probe and the stiffener
and so to start off with this is
inserted into the brain
the next step is to build up a well
around the insertion site so this can be
done either using dental cement
or a custom 3d printed piece those
polyamide wings are then attached to the
well for stability
next the connector is moved away from
the surgical arm
saline is then applied to dissolve the
peg that's holding the probe to the
stiffener
and then finally the stiffener is fully
removed so it's attached to the surgical
arm and the probe is
still in the brain and ready to record
and so next i wanted to go into the
structure for how we actually distribute
these devices under this project
and so after we fabricate and assemble
everything at livermore we then send all
of the devices to the lead lab
at ucsf so lauren frank's group is
responsible for the distribution
surgical training and troubleshooting
advice
so the first round of devices go to what
we are calling the core labs here
so these are labs that are located at
ucsf uc berkeley and university of
washington
and they're responsible for the surgical
development surgical training
device testing and feedback and so we
have lead labs that focus on rat
songbird mouse and non-human primates
so once they've refined the surgical
technique for each species model
they can then teach the surgery to the
support labs which you see on the bottom
here
and so these labs will also receive
devices from ucsf
and they're responsible for the device
testing as well as providing feedback so
this feedback will go up to the core
labs
up to ucsf and then ultimately back up
to us so that we can further
make design modifications
and so i wanted to walk through this
structure that we set up for this
iterative redesign of the polymer probes
so the first step involves the device
design for different animal models
and so this is done at livermore using
feedback that's provided by ucsf
the next step is that labs then pick
which designs will suit their animal
model or their studies
and so again i mentioned there's that
blank practice probe that
i talked about a couple slides ago and
so for the first pass we distribute
these blank practice probes to groups to
refine their surgical process
after that they then receive the actual
microelectrode arrays
so the next step once they pick their
design is that we then can fabricate and
distribute these probes
so again we fabricate and assemble at
livermore we then send all of these
probes to ucsf for further distribution
and finally the participating groups
will implant and provide feedback on the
designs
and again because this is an iterative
process we want to take into account
all of their feedback so that it can
feed the next round of cycle fabrication
and distribution
and so i've been speaking mainly so far
about the distribution of these 32 to
128 channel count probes
but what i also want to emphasize is a
really exciting thing that we're doing
in this program is also kind of pushing
the limits of what we're able to do
on the probe side to create an even
higher channel count probe
and so right now we're actively working
on creating a 512 channel count
probe and this involves four different
entities so at livermore we're
responsible for the polymer probe design
and probe microfabrication
lawrence berkeley national lab is
responsible for the integrated circuit
design
as well as the fabrication for the cmos
chip
spike gadget is a company based in san
francisco and they're responsible for
designing the channel acquisition system
and finally ucsf is responsible for the
probe distribution
system integration and software
development for this probe
and so because we all need to work
together to ultimately create one final
probe that can be
distributed to everybody there's a lot
of kind of these relationships at play
right i can't just make one decision and
assume it will not affect anybody else
and so to make sure that we all stay on
the same page and that we maintain
communication with each other
we've have periodic in-person meetings
it does help that we are all
somewhat located in the san francisco
bay area to do this
but when we can't do that which for
example now we also utilize
zoom slack dropbox and smartsheet to
stay on the same page
and so finally to wrap up i want to
emphasize that
at livermore because we do have this
these quality control practices we found
that this is absolute
absolutely key to producing consistent
and reliable probes
and finally funneling of the right
information to the right parties is very
important so whether that's information
on how to do the surgeries flowing from
the core labs to the support labs
or whether that's feedback from all the
labs making sure that it ultimately
makes its way back up to us so that we
can make
modifications to our designs for the
next round of probes
of these control of information is
important
and finally i wanted to talk about a few
challenges that we found from this
distribution project that perhaps we can
talk more about in the q
a so the first being that a lot of the
participating labs have a significant
hurdle of actually being able to test
the devices when they don't actually
have the funding to do the testing
secondly the refinement of these designs
does appear to be more species dependent
than anticipated so for example probes
that we thought would work for mouse and
rat
we thought might work for songbird but
we're finding that might be
actually not the case and so we're
looking at ways that we can refine some
of the dimensions to make it so that
they can work the songbird
and finally many steps in the post
fabrication assembly are actually done
serially
so once they're done taken out of the
clean room we actually assemble and
connectorize those
devices one by one and so my group is
looking at new ways that some of these
steps can be done in a batch process
and so with that i'd like to thank you
so much for your time i'd like to thank
my team members at livermore as well as
my collaborators in this project which
include rozzy huck
which is my co-pi at livermore lauren
frank
is the lead pi of this project at ucsf
peter dennis at lawrence
berkeley national lab beth buffalo at
university of washington
and matthias and magnus carlson as spike
gadgets and so with that i'd like to
wrap up my slides and i'll
be happy to introduce eric eatry at
carnegie mellon university
thank you
thank you for the introduction and thank
you all for joining us
my name is eric itri and this work uh
together with rohul panat and our teams
listed here
as well as mason chapman service group
is about a
fully customizable 3d printed
electrode array and the real purpose
of this array is to address the
challenges
that we experience
when we use electrodes so in a given
experiment say we want to hit
hippocampus striatum and prefrontal
cortexes and a mouse
this presents many issues uh this is a
target this is a multiple targets
we need a customized setup and ideally
at least for several of us we would like
to
do this in a freely moving animal
surface microelectrodes won't be able to
hit these deeper areas
and to hit this with multiple silicon
arrays or tetrodes
this would include neuropixels would be
costly
difficult though though potentially
doable though not so easy to do in a
freely moving animal
similarly more and more people are
looking to
incorporate electrophysiology with
imaging
so we may want to put electrodes around
the outside
or even in the middle of a window
and achieving this would be very
difficult to do
so together uh we've developed
an array called the cmu array which is a
3d nanoprinted
array that is capable of 6400 channels
and that's one shank per channel per
square centimeter and we can place these
channels
anywhere we want to uh with high density
and on any substrate actually everything
that you see here
including the circuit going out was 3d
printed
so this allows an incredible amount of
flexibility the shanks are very narrow
making even with this
high density of array makes it very easy
to penetrate the brain
just as a sense of the full
customizability of these arrays
we can print the our university's name
cmu here on the right we on panel g
that's a 512 channel array
and also part of this is that we can
not only get these dense and intricate
layouts we can make the tips pointed
it also allows us to route the signals
out
to any connector that we need so if
you're using an amnetics connector
we can use that samtech or as if that's
easy as well we're just 3d printing the
leads
in a fully customizable way but one
issue we had
with this density as well as
this wanting to have flexibility
is how to actually achieve this layout
without a
a printed chip
and so in order to do that we actually
as i mentioned before
are printing the entire chip and we're
doing it in a multi-level
uh procedure so we are printing pads for
all of our electrodes that can be
a millimeter high it can be four
millimeters high any
length that we want we're printing out
on every let
layer one set of leads then covering it
with
uh paralleling c then printing another
and another as we see as we go
left to right and then on top of this we
can
print the actual shanks that we want at
the depth and location
that that we desire and then this whole
chip can be implanted into the brain
either acutely
or chronically in terms of how well it
goes in
here's just an example that i showed you
before of that 100 shanks
being implanted into the brain we dip
this
[Music]
probe first and die leaving behind these
nice little marks and one of the
impressive things that
that 3d printing in these very
narrow shanks has enabled is that
we no longer have a need for a
specialized
equipment for introducing these
electrodes into the brain
this uh this probe was lowered into the
brain
just with your bench top stereotax
there's no need to shoot it in or
vibrate it in
and the damage it causes is actually
quite minimum here
if you look at this histology slide
and try and figure out where exactly the
shanks were
here's where the shanks were and it's
really difficult to see
any amount of tracing these this was an
acute prep
the shanks were lowered in for several
minutes uh
dozens of minutes and then pulled out
but the real proof in the pudding is the
quality of signal
uh and so unlike uh
silicon arrays with the spacing that we
have here we're only getting
one or two uh neurons per channel and
here's a
32 channels we've seen that most of
these
channels were getting good isolation of
neurons in this case
we're able to easily identify just with
envelope thresholding where those
[Music]
those two neurons are so we've developed
a very flexible array that
will enable anyone to
easily and quickly printing one of these
arrays only takes a
handful of hours um get a
specific targeted electrode and fairly
inexpensively that we can use in
any animal and in any
circumstance that you need but 3d
printing
isn't limited to just
this avenue we've actually been looking
into
delivery rather than just recording but
delivery of fluid or
light and so these electrode shanks can
actually be made hollow
opening up the possibility of fluid
delivery
or potentially in the future
microdialysis we haven't looked at that
so much
but allowing us to puff on a bit of drug
through the middle of these electrodes
and then look at the local and
long-distance
effects of these of the administering of
this drug
similarly we can also uh print polymer
that
can act as a waveguide here we have it
bending around
a corner
and what this really enables which i
think is
pretty fascinating is that if you have
an experiment
say you want to look at functional
connectivity throughout this
area of brain in vivo in a wake animal
you can devise as you will
an electrode to sample throughout that
3d printed volume
and intermixed on this electrode will be
recording sites as well
as wave guides which would enable you to
then
hope you can see the the blue dots here
flash through look at the responses
both locally and long distance
you can do these stimulations
in pair in paired in one area
or across different areas targeting the
inputs for whatever your recording is
so this really is a phenomenal amount of
flexibility
uh that this project has enabled um
though this project is actually uh quite
young
and i uh i think one of the the great
things that the organizers did here is
to get together
one the great ideas but also projects
that are at
many levels of development and so we've
really
seen uh in terms of how we've
been progressing forward first and
foremost a coordination between
engineers and biologists is very very
very important
uh it's it's never great to see people
who build a hammer and then go out
desperately looking for a nail and so
to have this alignment with either the
biological or clinical needs
is fundamental to early support and
early success
for the technology also looking ahead
at packaging not just the electrode
itself but packaging
and packaging uh at a larger
scaled up point of view
related to that also are the challenges
that we have for scaling up generally
the techniques that might be able to
make one or five or
20 probes are different from 500 or 1000
probes
and thankfully for this process like i
said we can print
several hundred shanks in just a matter
of hours
um but we're still looking ahead to the
challenges that
proper scaling up will have and then
last but last
not least always seek out resources
early and often for tech transfer
because the the real success of a
technology isn't that it can do
something
it's uh having people adopt that
technology and use it and for that
you typically have to go well beyond
just your lab or your
set of groups so that's an overview of
the
uh the cmu array some of the challenges
that we've faced in our trajectory
moving forward
i'd like to open this now up to the
live conversation and questions
i think we may have cindy maybe having
some technical problems
so uh until she comes back on
i think we may as well go ahead and get
started cindy i
apologize for you surfing your moderator
role but i felt like we should go
uh but uh well once you're back i will
step back so uh my name is lauren frank
uh oh there you are great hi sorry about
that
sorry i thought that there i was going
to be auto unmuted but i i was wrong
um so uh thank you everybody um so let
me let me go ahead and get started i
apologize for that
um so chong uh there were a lot of
questions um during your talk about
insertion that i think you got through
um but uh are there concerns about
breaking the elections when we insert
like is that part of why these bridges
take so long
or what is the most challenging thing
about these words
cindy thanks for the presidential
despite any
trained
um
okay maybe let's let's go on to uh
another question and we can sort of see
if uh support can help with your audio
um let me ask a question to uh tim
um so tim so at one level of electrode
distribution
either in terms of a uh quantity of
devices or a number of labs supported
does it make sense to transition to a
company and can you sort of put a number
on that
yeah i mean i guess just within my own
experience the
the the so we have three levels of
experience at that one is
supply to janalia labs and so
i wouldn't want to supply any
significant number of labs
more than just a handful unless i had a
paid technician
it is not appropriate work for graduate
students and postdocs
and so if you're going to supply even
half a dozen labs which is what i was
doing at janelia
i wouldn't do that with people who were
trainees by the definition of the nih
um i just don't think it's fair to them
and it doesn't really advance their
careers
but you can with a single technician you
can certainly supply
10 or 20 labs maybe even 30. i think
going beyond that is getting
to to be you know challenging but it can
be done
um and then and then a few trends and
and so
um the the experience that that i had
with
transitioning to to production was
it depends on the market is that if
you're going to sell things for a living
and you're going to do it for your
primary job i think you need to be
thinking in terms of
many hundred probes and many tens of
labs preferably hundreds of labs
um that that uh and it depends on you
know what the what the per lab
buy is that you know neural pixels is is
pretty rigid
their minimum order is six thousand
euros worth of probes
uh and so uh and yet they still you know
are approaching 300 labs worldwide with
more than 4 000 probes delivered
uh that's probably not a typical example
for
um something launched out of an academic
group because it takes a lot of legwork
to get
to that level and so i think the the
the simple answer to your question is
you know think
um many tens of thousands of dollars
worth of devices sold before you can
even consider
a part-time company and hundreds of
thousands of dollars sold if you have
permanent employees per year
okay thank you very much um so let me
sort of go through maybe some of these
uh technical questions for us we can act
about the electrodes and then we can
talk
a little bit more about the distribution
um we have a number of questions here
about um also the the 3d printed probes
so uh eric or rokulkanat can
you maybe tell us about the uh different
materials that you can use in
your 3d printing both for the electrode
and also for the insulation of these
devices
yeah so i can talk about the the
materials
so currently we are we started with
silver that was the
easiest available uh nanoparticle ink
that we could
we could use with the aerosol jet
printer um
so the the first attempt was to create
these silver shanks
and then electroplate gold on top of
them
um the second one is we are currently
able to print
a gold uh silver shanks as well
right uh but they have they have
you know their own uh the process needs
to tweak to each materials obviously so
um we are able to print gold
uh but we we the next steps will be
to look at platinum and and platinum
rhodium which would which would be uh
again we will have to tweak the process
but
we believe that this can be done yeah
so currently at this point time for
metals it is
silver and gold and for insulation
materials
typically we print polyamide but we are
also able to print pdms um
as an as an insulation material uh
which could which would give us a choice
of multiple polymers for insulating
these
these
very cool and i think i saw a slew of uh
similar materials questions come in
um for for allison as well um so do you
want to
talk a little bit about this sort of
range of materials it was it was very
cool how you were talking about having
sort of dedicated equipment
um but what sort of the range of
materials that you can use with uh some
of your designs
sure so especially with regards to
the clean room tools that are set aside
for
the fabrication of these probes there's
actually a very short list
especially with regards to the type of
metal so for example we can deposit
platinum iridium
gold amongst a few other metals but
there is a very short list and we try
and keep that
uh very controlled because we do have
the capability of
uh putting this these as a human which
is really great about our facility
um but i guess related to that does mean
that there's less
or fewer materials that perhaps that we
can
kind of use to explore and luckily
because the clean room is not just
consist of our tools there are also
you know other tools that are more for
general use for other groups as well
and we do have access to some of those
other tools to do kind of more
exploratory research
but at the same time i think you do lose
a little bit on some of that
ability to do that quality control
throughout the process
fair enough okay sean are you with us
now
hello can you try speaking for a second
question um
um all right so maybe let's start uh
talking about you know some of the
uh questions about distribution
um and so here's a question
so and i let me let me post this sort of
broadly um
probably all of you are working with uh
labs
that um you know are going to be the
initial alpha testers of your technology
um what is the funding model because it
takes an awful lot of work for a new lab
to bring up a new technology do you
think that this should only be done
with full-time personnel and for example
and who should that personnel be should
it be a um
a technician a grad student a postdoc
like what's the right model for that and
maybe i'll ask lauren first since i saw
you nodding your head
yeah cindy it's a really great point i
think this is one of the challenges
we've had is we we you know getting
probes to other labs is great but having
them have the personnel
to actually test the probes and give us
feedback when for example they may not
be funded to do so is a really big
ask and so i think you know for this
sort of thing
they're they're really we you know we're
fortunate to have some funded labs but
for the others it's their goodwill and
their time
and so i think it's not a great model
for actually doing the kind of
distributed testing
and so you know i think for example
what's done with neuropixels has been
spectacular
right but tim has had this amazing sort
of team i think of people and himself
dedicated to this and most of the rest
of us don't have that
so i think i think from my perspective
the idea of having grants that really
provide money for the distribution and
testing is a critical phase of this
and then moving it to companies as
quickly as possible
for anything that looks like it has
potential but it's a hard road
actually maybe then alaska tim next so
are neuropixels so great that people can
get them up and running for free or at
the beginning of this was it sort of
harder to get them up and running in
labs around the country
uh so cindy you know neural pixels is a
really bad
test case for nih funded work because
we had um partners with deep pockets to
start with
um you know janellia is
historically sort of an unfairly deep
pocketed and so we just committed
my group's very large budget and the
large budgets of other labs
to do the testing both and write the
software
um and and the allen institute was
similarly
posed i mean they had deep pockets and
they had their own internal budgets
the other the other partner was was ucl
or the sainsbury welcome center through
uh john o'keefe's lab and we we got a
grant from the welcome trust
on their behalf 1.5 million pounds
900 000 of those pounds were used to pay
for fab
and six hundred thousand pounds were
used to pay for
test and john complained bitterly
throughout the entire four years that he
was losing money on every test
and so i think from the standpoint of
just you know listening
to how much does it really cost
it's hard to keep the real test and
design and feedback budget below the fab
budget
it's kind of a 50 50 deal and and so
now that that i've written you know some
nih grants to support that
that's not a bad guess is that if you're
if it's going to cost you
in the in the lab to deliver device per
protest
you know a million dollars you better
have a million dollar budget to feed the
academic side of it
to actually do the real testing and to
inter interface with the engineering
design groups
all along because it's an iterative
process you all you write a spec
they go to work they find out gee whiz
that's really hard and it's really
expensive do you really need to stick to
that spec
or how about can we back up a little on
that spec or on the other side we made
mistakes and said look we just forgot
something that was really important
we gotta have it what can we trade you
know we're willing to relax other specs
if you give us that capability
uh and again and so those people have to
get
paid you know they have to pay tuition
they you know all that jazz and so i
think
a good guess is 50 50. if you think you
know you're spending 300
to make a device just in fab costs
you should have another 300 to pay the
people who are going to use it and that
doesn't count assembly cindy but
the devices we get are assembled by our
fabricators
this once the assembled and ready to go
you need that much money again
to just make sure that they are ready to
go out the door
so i'll do that i think in terms of
personnel effort we're sort of in
agreement yeah
it's about a 50 50 of how much work it
is to sort of get something up and
running
uh eric and rahul is that is that
similar to your experience about the
distribution of effort between you know
the very first users
and the fabricators
yeah that that is what we've seen so far
and i mean we are both on this brain
initiative grant together
and and split it down the middle so uh
yeah in terms of the effort and the cost
it's absolutely true
uh and then one sort of caveat
underneath
all this that i want to point out is
particularly if you are early days
it is so very important to
have a nail already
and be building a hammer rather than
i think i can build some fun electrodes
and have no biologists
actually in need of that and i think
that's largely
reflective in what all of us have been
talking about but
too often i've seen engineers uh
trying to to go it alone whereas
biologists
are really the end goal um so don't
discount them
yeah i i think i think i totally second
what eric just mentioned
just being able to build a device right
this was a cool technology that
that we were able to
[Music]
build and um using this has a lot of
fluid dynamics to it
but at the same at the end of the day
when we are building
um a a probe right
with different shank lens different
materials and
and other things such as the hollow
shanks that eric just showed
um it really boils down to what is
needed to
to study specific biological questions
right what is useful to biology
is what we need to focus on and and
that's what you know i'm
i'm happy to mention we are
of your devices uh can you hear me now
this time
yes i can hear you now okay great
perfect
thank you for hanging on there so uh i
guess there was a question regarding
whether these probes
are resilient enough during insertion
and implementation i guess
but they are indeed very dedicated but
if we can avoid
applying big forces on the which we do
for any type of probes
they're all fine so uh as an example if
we pull the
electrodes into the tissue they are fine
we never had failures
with that if we pull the electrode out
of the brain issues they
typically can survive that as well we
never had them break
and so uh if we can avoid bounding the
probes into anything so
which if you are careful doesn't happen
though you're
you're really fine i guess that answers
the question
sure and just because we didn't have uh
before
um during some of these other questions
um how have your how has your experience
been with uh
translating some of your probes to other
labs um are you having challenges in
terms of uh
how much time it takes for that other
lab to get up and running for example
all right thank you thanks for the
opportunity i do want to
apologize to my collaborators you know
thank you very much for your insurance
team but i do want to applaud that if
you haven't received our approach as pro
as i promised
i said over over the the question system
that
i'm very cheap because i promise to many
many lives
but in reality like tim has mentioned
that it's
very difficult to have a students
wish who are on training for
their as their main goal in my lab so
it's hard to
force them to support other labs without
any scientific
output so with that said it's
it's been uh it's been a long procedure
and we had some progress but
it's definitely not efficient enough or
as i expected
so as i mentioned we are trying to uh
explore the way to commercially deliver
these probes to other labs
uh but in a way supported by federal
grant
and we hope to to ramp this up so that
it can be
uh standing alone and self-sufficient
for the rest of his life
so um everyone who are trying to get our
probes
or any probes from this session stay
tuned i think everyone is working super
hard to deliver them
so i want to talk a little bit more with
you some questions here about the
commercialization but first i want to go
back to allison you said something
uh during your talk about um national
labs
being in a particularly good position
you know to to do this
um what do you foresee as the sort of
role of livermore and national labs in
distributing devices are there is it you
know
what kind of technologies are the things
that are quite you know commercializable
or too advanced to be easily
commercializable where like where is the
what is the role of national labs that's
a really good question cindy and it's
actually a discussion we've had a lot
within our group at livermore as well um
because we do think of ourselves as kind
of right in between
maybe academia and industry and so
while we're not allowed to you know
actually sell devices and distribute
them
in that sense and we can really only do
it through grants
but i think what's great is that we are
able to kind of do some of these more
slightly larger scale fabrications of
perhaps more novel technologies for
kind of this mid-level distribution but
i mean one thing
that we have discussed is whether or not
we can move
some of our you know more basic
devices to a fab for example that could
enable other labs to kind of use our
technology
and get them up to speed um so that they
can kind of jump into kind of these
uh more as we kind of try and push these
technologies even further whether that's
you know
adding different modalities to the
probes themselves expanding beyond efiz
or whether that's you know even higher
channel counts
so that's kind of where i see the
national labs as being in part of all
this distribution
sure so okay so now maybe let's talk a
little bit about commercialization we
have a question here um is there room in
the market
for all these probes or the panelists
expect that the market will consolidate
on a few of these designs
would these groups plan to collaborate
to encourage that
consolidation um i don't know who to
pick on here first i guess i see lauren
nodding again
but excellent yeah i think it's a good
question
i guess i would make the point that
different different needs drive
different devices
so it is my guess although i would love
to be wrong about this
that the the unit stability that you can
get
from flexible devices will never be
matched by silicon
in that you can record for many days but
the units move up and down that's the
classic observation as far as i
understand
which means that these devices are
suited for different things on the other
hand the you know the density of cmos
uh sort of things is harder to get in
the flexible devices so
i can imagine that you know a set of
devices will
survive but i think it's actually going
to be
probably less which ones are best and
more which ones have a decent business
plan
right you know like neuropixels will not
go anywhere i think thanks to all the
work of tim and his colleagues to make
this incredibly robust foundation
i'm hoping that the polymer probes also
have that um you know it'd be great to
see the 3d printed probes have that
similarly
but but but setting that up in terms of
the
foundation of a distribution pipeline is
tough
and i'll just add you know as part of
the work uh we're collaborating with
chong and lan
on develop distribution of their probes
one of the things that we proposed
is indeed a test across different
devices to directly put them in the same
animals at the same time to ask the
question you know
can we really say oh look these devices
are good for this these other devices
are good for this other thing
um and i think that would create market
space for multiple devices but
it's still to be done yeah one one
comment i have on the same question
is uh uh the the way i
i look at it and i i come from a micro
electronics industry i was at
intel for about a decade so when uh it's
it's like uh in pathfinding phase right
we are in research phase when we are
looking at different technologies
but some of the technologies that have
already
uh matured they will dominate for about
five to ten years
before being replaced or modified by the
newer ones that come in
so so it it might be like a sawtooth
type of
trajectory rather than just saying that
a few of
the the technologies that will kind of
hold
uh true forever because newer
advances will always be coming right
from multiple labs
sure let me let me add something since
since
um there's a different perspective i
think for me first of all
i'd like to push back on lauren is is
that there are many publications of six
months of stability for silicon probes
cemented to skulls and rodents so you
just don't need flexible electro
elect technology to achieve that outcome
um but not of the same neurons however
you know i think that's that remains to
be proven i would argue there's no
possibility we aren't recording from the
same neurons but they do move and so
you're gonna have to do something to
prove that you that you've got the same
ones i think that can be done
i think much more importantly is that we
have seen
many reports from high quality users
that
ca1 hippocampal neurons are not stable
across many months
with silicon probes either neuropixels
or others
i don't understand why you could have
accused the old silicon probes of being
too short an array and
it moved you can't accuse that from
neural pixels you can't get lost
they just go away we've seen the same
thing in
cerebellum with fewer reports
with the same users getting you know
just month after month after month of
stability and cortex
um the thing that puzzles me now lauren
is that
that the people who are using them in
hippocampus say i just can't keep them
more than a month or six weeks so
playing your experiments accordingly are
loving them in in anterior cortex which
is posterior
and and deep and so why you can get such
great recordings over time in interim
cortex when you can't get them in ca one
puzzles me but
you know what i'm telling people is look
it you know the silicon approaches don't
seem to be working in
in places that you should try something
else
so yeah i i we could actually spend a
lot of time here it would actually be
really i think fun for our audience
to get us all talking about the uh
relative pros and cons
of these different devices i personally
think there's there's room for a lot and
it's a sort of per experiment
uh sort of thing but i want to get to
this uh
other question here um which i thought
was really interesting from
nick steinmetz um for some of the probes
that have extremely difficult insertions
and surgeries um and i can also imagine
for probes that have very different uh
difficult
rig setups you know where it's just sort
of really hard to stand up or rig
um are there any thoughts towards
distributing data sets rather than
distributing
probes perhaps some sort of observatory
model so have any of you
thought about you know whether the right
thing to do is to build
one amazing rig you know that that does
your thing as best as possible
and try to you know farm out uh time on
that rig
for for data sets i'll open this up to
everybody
i think can i say something about that
oh you can hear me okay great i guess
that's a great model
and noah actually has focused on in the
past
but indeed i have thought about this i
talked to lauren about this
since years ago i think this is a great
idea
especially if coming to this you know
nowadays everyone is trying to record
from thousands
or if not hundreds of thousands of
neurons at the time
this data set and the recording rig and
the cost is enormous and the time cost
and the economic cost of doing this
becomes really really prohibiting
and sorting the data everything becomes
prohibited
for individual labs to do so and animals
are not
and plus surgical technique is difficult
to implant
many probes one animal if we can
come up with a unified model or
a scheme we can do experiment we can
totally do this experiment
in our lab and post the data somewhere
probably online and
post all the parameters and experimental
setup everything so that
everyone can analyze the same data it
would be great i totally like this idea
yeah okay yeah just
let's see maybe eric oh there
erica rahul yeah
yeah okay just just yeah just one
comment on the on the same topic
is uh uh as any standardization
is going to lower the barrier for entry
for many labs
and as my discussion with eric has made
it clear
um um cost as well as lack of
standardization
are the the two major obstacles in uh
in expanding the market right so i don't
know the number but maybe let's assume
100
or 200 uh thousand uh
probes are used per year to take it to a
million or two million i think the the
cost needs to come down significantly
and
so is standardization that that is
needed so this is absolutely a
very good thing to have
okay so we're coming up on one o'clock
here so i'm just going to ask uh
one last question and maybe we can do
this by
show of hands uh people want to know um
and asking questions are these probes
available
and should they contact you if they are
interested
in using your technology for these
experiments
so maybe by show of hands
okay all right and you guys i think
there's there's many different stages
but um yeah so there's i think
everybody's email address
is very we're all very googlable and so
um i think there's hopefully a lot of
interest that we've been able to drum up
uh during this session um we really want
to see these technologies make their way
into more people's hands over the next
few years
i think that's the end so thank you very
much for attending
thank you cindy sure thank you thank you
thank you